Salut à tous c'est Pêcheur de Trésors
Vous reconnaissez sûrement Vincent, nous sommes de retour une fois de plus avec lui !
Pour un nouvel épisode à Chalon Sur Saône
On commence un nouveau Road Trip à l'improviste
C'est ça et on a décidé de faire étape ici parce que nous avons déjà trouvé des folies sous ce pont dans une précédente vidéo
Elle sera en description, il y a une cité juste à côté, il devrait y avoir des objets liées à la délinquance
On va voir ce que l'on trouve, c'est parti !
Je crois que j'ai eu quelque chose tout au fond de la vase
Alors qu'est-ce que nous avons de beau ?
Oh une montre une montre
Yes !
Ce n'est pas de la marque mais bon...
Timex expédition
Il n'y a pas d'eau à l'intérieur
Elle ne fonctionne pas mais je pense qu'elle est imperméable
Rasta garde ma montre
Là j'ai attrapé un truc les gras, c'est bien aimanté
J'ai accroché quelque chose aussi
Un antivol
une serrure
C'est bon signe
ça vient peut-être d'un coffre fort
On a un gros morceau qui arrive
Il paraît gros parce qu' il est dans la vase, mais une fois sorti il sera plus léger
Oui il aura l'air moins lourd
La quantité de bulle que ça fait !
Il va se coller à la pale planche en fer
Il est collé au bord non ?
Ah ok
nous ne sommes pas accrochés au bord mais...
Attends je vais l'attraper
Sacré quantité de boue, ok bien joué !
C'est dégueulasse
Qui veut une roue de secoure ?
La fameuse voiture rouge
le camion *
Ah le camion rouge ?
Ok
Effectivement c'est une selle
ça vient sûrement d'une Honda 125, une ancienne
Allez nous avons un gros morceau
Nos deux aimants sont collés dessus
Ouais
Ah ouais ouais d'accord...
Sans déconner...
Aie ! ça va ??
Juste ici il y a comme un sac, et c'est lourd
Il est rempli
Rempli d'eau, de vase, je ne sais pas de quoi, mais en tout cas il y a un sac
j'en suis sûr
Ok
Par là
Il faut le soulever tout doucement pour essayer de ne pas perdre ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur
C'est bon je l'ai
Doucement
Très bien repéré !
Place à l'ouverture
Oh mec !
C'est les affaires d'un sac à main
Non !
venez voir !
Les gars !
Il y a des lunettes
C'est les affaires d'une femme
Il y a un truc ici aussi
Ils ont lesté le sac avec des graviers
Ah oui lesté avec des cailloux, purée !
Ah ouais !
C'est un morceau d'autoradio
Oui ça appartenait à une femme c'est certain
Ouais !
Ils ont rempli le sac de graviers
Vous avez un trésor ?
Un petit
Une carte de fidélité
Il reste du parfum à l'intérieur
C'est vrai ?
On pourrait l'offrir à notre hôte de ce soir
Essaie d'appuyer
vas y
il faut que je retrouve le trou déjà
Ouais t'es prêt ?
Attends, vas y
ça sent bon
Ouais ça va il sent encore bon
Ah il y a des pièces de monnaie
Il en reste ?
Allez il y a des sous ! Ahaha
C'est bon ça ! en plus il n'y a pas uniquement des pièces rouges
Il y a des pièces de 20 centimes là
Il faut regarder les années, 2008 celle-là
poudre compacte
Belle trouvaille
Le fond de teint aussi a l'air encore bien
Je pense que ça se garde tout ça
Boucle d'oreilles
Tant que ça n'a pas pris l'eau...
Est-ce qu'il y a une date d'expiration là dessus ?
Ce n'est pas une carte bleue mais une carte de fidélité
Mais pourquoi les voleurs se sont pris là tête à lester ça au fond de l'eau ?
C'est vraiment le niveau 0 de la preuve
C'est quoi ça ?
C'est pour ranger les cartes bleues mais c'est vide
bon ok
C'est sympa, il y en a sûrement d'autres
C'est impressionnant d'avoir réussi à remonter ça avec l'aimant
Ouais je ne sais pas trop ce qui était aimanté
peut-être l'autoradio, ou ça
Les deux, ouais
Il y a des jetons à l'intérieur ?
Non, j'ai crus aussi mais ça fait partie de la boîte
AH AH AH ! Une chaîne
Dorée
Oh non elle est aimantée...
Quand même !
Elle est belle
C'est la classe
Ecoute après la montre, la chaîne
Et oui
Elle est magnétique mais jolie
Tiens moi ça
C'est du plaqué or peut-être
Elle a perdu sa couleur un peu
Elle est un peu cuivrée en dessous
Oui c'était plaqué mais la couleur a changé
C'est plaqué doré mais or je ne pense pas
Non pas d'or
De toute façon elle est aimantée
Oui elle est très aimantée
Et seulement plaquée avec un revêtement doré
C'est déjà bien
Tu peux me l'attacher s'il te plaît ?
Non c'est la mienne
Alors je vais te la mettre
Non non finalement
trop tard
ça va te porter bonheur
Et oui
Il dit oui et maintenant il n'assume plus parce qu'elle est pleine de vase
Non
En plus elle est trop serrée
Ah oui en effet
c'est un collier de chien
j'ai aimanté un truc un peu lourd
Ou alors c'est l'effet de la vase
Alors mon style est comment ?
C'est la classe en réalité
Même serré comme ça ?
Oui c'est vraiment la classe
ça se porte de cette façon
Oh un rétroviseur
De scooter
Ouais
Et ça c'est un petit bijoux
Une boucle d'oreille ou une bouton de vêtement
peut-être
Je vérifierai, je le garde
j'ai eu quelque chose là bas au fond
Des pédales de voiture
Il y en a une qui est rose
Et ça c'est une pochette pour accrocher son téléphone portable
c'est un étuis en cuir
Made in France
Le Tanneur
mais bon il est cassé, dommage
Sinon je l'aurais gardé tu vois
Avec la petite chaîne et tout, c'est un objet sympa
ça doit aller aussi avec les affaires de la fille
Ah oui un pédalier de voiture
Et une pédale rose
Elle sont minuscules et c'est bizarre la pédale rose
Qui peint ses pédales ?
une cuillère de pêche
Vous l'avez vu, c'est la première étape du road trip
Et Quentin a quelque chose
On a déjà pêché ici, mais il y a tellement de choses les gars...
On creuse dans la vase avec l'aimant Barbarian, c'est impressionnant tout ce que l'on peut sortir
D'ailleurs si vous cherchez à vous équiper avec un aimant
Celui-ci est neuf
Et il vient tout droit de chez Maison de la détection
Le lien est en description et le code promo PECHEURDETRESORS offre 5% sur toute la boutique de Maison de la détection
c'est l'aimant Barbarian qui peut tirer jusqu'à 1600 kilos
On ne pêche plus qu'avec celui-là
regardez ce beau lancé
ils vendent des packs complets directement avec les cordes, ici ce sont des cordes 8mm
Elles font bien le travail et nous permettent de lancer l'aimant à une vingtaine de mètres
un antivol
Il n'est pas vilain celui-là
C'est bien un antivol ? Il a donc une serrure ?
Oui certainement
Ah oui la serrure est là, elle est bien abîmée
Il est costaud mais cela n'a pas suffit
Il devait être mal installé
S'ils ne sont pas coupés c'est qu'ils étaient mal mis
Viens mon petit
Allez file
Va dans l'herbe
C'est bien
non ne te mets pas dans la ferraille, viens
Viens là
Mets toi ici
Assis
Allez-y à deux
Pas le bord en fer pas le bord
t'es déjà dessus
Oh un cadre entier !
AH non c'est bon je ne suis pas accroché au bord
Bravo
Depuis le temps qu'on pêche ici, il fallait bien en trouver un
ça reste une découverte sympa
Il me paraît étroit ce cadre, ce doit être un petit scooter
Oui c'est un 50cm3 ou 125
Bien joué
Merci
il est toujours au milieu de la route lui, le fameux dos d'âne
C'est un beau morceau
Allez
Ah non il faut un autre aimant
Il y a un second objet ce n'est pas le même
Ah oui c'était celui-là et l'autre aimant est collé au bord non ?
C'était ça ?
Oui et l'autre aimant est accroché à la berge en fer
C'était impossible de l'éviter
1,2,3
C'est bon
On va tous les accrocher...
Et voilà
C'est un vérin pour les coffres de voitures
Là j'ai quelque chose
c'est marrant ça
Je croyais que c'était une canné à pêche mais non
Ouais ça ressemblait bien à un morceau de canne à pêche
Après tu peux quand même pêcher avec
Non c'est un javelot, t'es prêt ?
vas y
Il est pourri ton javelot
C'est un panneau de signalisation
Et ça c'est quoi ?
Ce ne serait pas un disque antivol pour les motos ?
Oui je crois
Ce serait cool de trouver des menottes
Ouais, on en a trouvé une fois
Une paire de menottes découpée, il ne restait qu'un côté
Ah c'est un signe
C'est bon signe
oui c'est bon signe ça
Euh...
Ou plutôt mauvais signe, c'est nul
Très mauvais ce signe
je pense que je ne peux que trouver mieux que toi
je crois que je l'ai perdu au bord
C'est un très mauvais signe
J'ai quand même une pile électrique
ça dépollue c'est déjà ça
Je crois que c'est un alternateur
Ouais
Du cuivre
On aime le cuivre
Oui le vieux portable !
Et un couteau
C'est un couteau pakistanais encore
On en a trouvé un au premier pont là bas
Superbe
Ton truc est beaucoup moins bien
Regardez moi ce couteau
Nikel il s'ouvre et tout
Aujourd'hui on voit l'effet de l'aimant neuf
ça joue
Et il est en très bon état
C'est un cerclage de tonneau ça
ouais
C'est bien un cerclage de tonneau
Alcatel
je viens de sortir un espèce de réservoir moi
Ah ouais ?
Je ne sais pas ce que c'est
ça ça date du début des années 2000 aussi
Ouais
Ouah, un volant !
Ah ben on va la reconstruire la voiture
ça c'est drôle
C'est bien abîmé par contre
C'est un volant de vieille voiture, je dirais de 2 Chevaux ou quoi
Une petite voiture, peut-être une 4L
Couteau !
Bien joué
Il est mieux le mien
AH pas sûr !
il y a un personnage dessus
Ah oui !
Avec un accordéon
Un joueur d'accordéon !
J'ai un couteau super beau et doré
Vraiment joli, en plus il est gravé avec des initiales, MM
MN ou MM
Ah ouais stylé
Et tu m'as dis que le tiens était mieux ?
Peut-être pas finalement
Encore un personnage, qui fait du basket cette fois !
Ah oui c'est un panier de Basket
Et de deux
Regardez déjà le gros tas
Là j'ai un énorme morceau
On va y aller doucement
Il vient
Encore un cadre ou quoi ?
Attention au bord en fer
ouah il est beau celui-là !
un cadre de Peugeot 103
En bon état
Même dans cet état certains collectionneurs sont prêts à le racheter
Oh !
Mais non c'est quoi ?
Du cuivre
c'est juste plaqué cuivre non ?
Non, tout en cuivre, c'est cette partie qui est en métal seulement
Ah ouais ouais ouais
pas mal, bon tu le gardes alors ?
Boarf
Je crois qu'il ne reste pas d'essence à l'intérieur
Il est beau quand même
regardez
Vincent vient de trouver un Minitel les gars
c'est une première en pêche à l'aimant ça
C'est incroyable
Attends c'est quoi ?
Il est fermé, attends
comment ça s'ouvre ?
C'est bien un minitel
Il y a la prise Ethernet
Et la prise téléphone
Ah ouais
C'est qu'il est refermé sur lui même en fait
Ah ouais !! Mais c'est le clavier !
oui il est complet !
il y a un clavier intégré
Et le clavier marche en plus
c'est magique de trouver un Minitel, franchement belle trouvaille
t'imagines le temps que ça doit faire qu'il est sous l'eau
Et là tu le branches puis il marche
C'est incroyable il faut le sécher et le brancher
ça ne m'étonnerait même pas
Un Minitel quoi !
Alcatel
Alcatel, comme le téléphone portable
on a le kit Alcatel les gars
le portable et le minitel
C'est bon on l'a eu
c'est un siège de voiture
mais de voiture ancienne encore
je vais couvrir mon tatouage avec
C'est bon je peux me faire tatouer le visage maintenant
j'aurais juste à me mettre ça sur le visage
regarde Op
Là c'est bon signe c'était bien sous le pont
Olala
Un morceau de carter de scooter, tu l'as attrapé sur la seule partie magnétique
Ouais tout le reste est en aluminium
Bien joué
Oh !
Il est beau celui-là
C'est de la marque
Edition limitée
Couteau à pain
C'est un couteau à pain mais il est beau
Celui-là a fait un meurtre
Ouais je pense, encore un meurtre au couteau à pain
Et crack
On va pouvoir s'en servir de celui-là
C'est pas ceux qu'on échange au supermarché contre les autocollants ?
Non non ça c'est du luxe et ça vaut au moins 50 €
Ah ça va alors
regardez on dirait un petit peu un tiroir caisse
C'est bizarre
Il y a un miroir dedans, c'est étrange
je vais l'ouvrir pour voir ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur
Ola
Un rasoir
Et une boîte
Avec un F
une cuillère ouais
Purée l'état de cette boîte
Encore un rasoir
une écrevisse
Et et et et et
Un tube de Fixodent
Ah oui tu as raison !
le tube est ouvert
C'est donc une sorte de boîte de pharmacie
Un truc dans le genre
C'est original
C'est du dentifrice
ça aimante au bord là
La marque du dentifrice c'est Email
Email Diamant
C'est vachement vieux d'après le design du dentifrice
Ah oui avec l'espèce de troubadour
Ouais ouais
T'en veux un ?
Euh c'est du maquillage ça
C'est parfait c'est pour mes ongles des pieds
Remet la photo encore
Ah il est de retour le signe !
Il s'est dit bon je m'en fous des aimants maintenant je passe
Ouais ça fait 3 heures qu'il attendait
Bien joué !!
Elle est belle
C'est quoi comme marque ?
Elle est super belle
Longines
Quoi Longines ??
Arrête, fais voir !!!
Original Master Collection
Elle est en super bon état !
Tu vois le mouvement à l'intérieur
Attends attends attends attends
Mec attends
Attends parce que si c'est vraiment le Longines que je connais il y en a pour des billets là
je te le dis
ça va me payer mon aimant ça
Ah bah alors là gros en plus c'est une vraie ça
Ouah le truc !!!
C'est le moment de financer l'aimant
Arrête !
C'est la pile de la montre
Non j'espère qu'elle ne marche pas à piles
Oh ben j'espère que non
je crois que c'est le truc le plus chère que vous ayez trouvé avec l'aimant
Arrête !
C'est clair et net, je suis sûr de moi
Moi je fais la montre nulle et lui il fait la belle
Bah oui
3600€
Pas mal pas mal
A force de la secouer le balancier la recharge
C'est ça
maintenant j'aurais mon aimant et une montre
Les connaisseurs en commentaires n'hésitez pas à nous donner des infos, elle est superbe
regarde comme ça brille
Ouais elle fonctionne
Elle marche !
Elle est comme neuve c'est incroyable
Faudrait peut-être enlever le bracelet
Elle n'est pas dans l'eau depuis longtemps
ça c'est de la découverte, félicitations !
Il la mérite parce qu'il a persévéré
Il a continué toute la journée alors qu'il a un aimant de 300kg de force
Avec un tout petit aimant il a sondé tous les côtés du pont
Et ça a fini par payer
Un petit téléphone
Imagines si tu vois le dernier message du téléphone : "C'est bon j'ai la montre"
Ou même "j'ai fais tomber la montre"
Une poêle ?
Une toute petite
Pour faire comme dans le jeu PUBG
Un câble peritel
Pour brancher les TV
Encore un portable
Enfin un demi portable
Encore un pneu
Le deuxième pneu à côté de l'autre
Ah ça a giclé !
ça recommence
Bien dégueulasse
J'ai le seau
Attention à tes pieds
Et voilà comme neuf
Là bas au bord il y a encore des trucs
Oh regarde
Il y a encore le pieds à l'intérieur
Arrête je vais vomir
Oh purée s'il y a le pieds dans la botte...
Bon allez une deuxième botte ou pas ?
ce serait drôle
Un aimant !
Bien joué
Il est à qui ?
C'est le miens
Il est *** ce Quentin
Il a laissé l'aimant dans l'eau exprès pour me filmer
Une pile électrique
belle dépollution !
Je vous fait une dernière découverte ensuite ce sera le moment de se quitter
Avant la suite du road trip
Oui oui, de se quitter pour l'instant
Et là je vous remonte une petite rolex
Ouais ?
Normalement il y a d'autres montres, on en a déjà remonté deux
Jamais deux sans trois
C'est bien beau la chance du débutant, mais maintenant je veux une rolex
Il y croit là
la rolex la rolex
Oh il y a un truc qui brille
C'est quoi ?
Ouah c'est nul
C'est un barillet de serrure
Coup dur
Ouais mais en or quand même !
C'est du laiton
Nous on se dit à la semaine prochaine pour la suite du voyage, on sera davantage dans le nord
On ne sait pas trop ou, on verra !